[Music]
zach is with us zacks in atlanta hi zach
how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
uh it's a quick question i have
about 8 500 in credit cards between two
credit card debts
and a vehicle with
a vehicle with 23 000 which is paid for
through my company every month so that's
kind of besides the point but no it's
not my question is
okay well i i got you but the the main
reason i was calling was should i
combine the two credit cards and get a
personal loan
with a lower interest rate to pay off
the credit cards
okay what do you make
uh
65
okay
well we teach folks zack if you are new
to our stuff to be extremely intense
unbelievably focused
cut your lifestyle to nothing
scorched earth
no life yes until you clear these debts
have you heard that stuff said by ramsey
people before oh absolutely okay that's
what i've been listening to here lately
now given that as our scenario making 65
000 how fast are you going to pay off 8
500
should be fast well what's fast
uh if i if i do the budgeted app like
i'm i'm working on which the first month
didn't go as planned like i'll talk
about um
six months okay good all right and so
really what we're discussing with your
question then is interest rate on eight
thousand dollars for six months
ten percent change
for one year would be an eight hundred
dollar change
so a 10 change in interest rate
by getting a different loan
on 8 500 is a 400 dollar swing
follow me all right okay
and 400 is nice if you send it to me
rachel will cash the check i'll take it
okay
but the uh you see but here's here's my
point okay the reason we're doing this
math out is this
it's okay to do what you're talking
about doing
the problem with it is it makes you feel
like you did something
right but you still have the debt yeah
you what you did was 400
and you don't have a 400 problem you
have a 31 000
problem right and so
you know and you've already ascertained
listen you're already ahead of the curve
because you've already figured this out
i'm doing my budget didn't work right
the first month i'm learning how to do
this i'm building new muscles that i
didn't have before you're on you're on
track to be winning with this act you're
very impressive
so but what i'm pointing out is is that
the math
says the important thing to work on is
living on nothing and paying this debt
off super fast because that's eight
thousand dollars in six months the
question you asked about is 400 dollars
in six months so if you only do the 400
change you didn't do anything
right
you do the 8 000 change and you don't do
the 400 change you're still out of debt
right so you're the secret sauce not the
interest rate because it's such a short
term and it's such a
small amount of money in general as in
the scope of your life and where you're
going to see the momentum zach is not
just in the math which is what we're
doing right to the idea of taking well
should i just take a personal loan to
you know combine the credit cards and
just have one loan with lower interest
all that's like it's math talk
but when you get in that change of wow i
am i'm literally sacrificing my
lifestyle i am saying no to things and
i'm throwing money at it that's the
momentum that's what's going to get you
to win
long term and to pay this off it's not
going to be the math and you can do that
and that's the problem is i think we get
so caught up in the math when we think
about money so your question is not
invalid because it's like oh yeah that
makes sense if we're just talking about
math but we're not talking about math in
order to completely change the way you
handle money and to build wealth over
the long term it's your behavior that
changes and so by you saying
this little math of 400
i don't even i'm not even going to mess
with because i'm going to focus so much
on what i can do
and changing you know your budget
putting money away and i mean going
through the baby steps that's where
you're going to see a lot of progress i
sense that you're going to be making
more than the minimum payments that i
have right you're going to keep the debt
if you were going to keep the debt for
five years then it would be a big deal
to get the personal loan right
but you're not right so yeah so you're
already convinced but let me keep
teaching our audience with your example
okay
um the uh the other thing is this the
words that we use all of us reveal what
is going on in our heart and you said
something very interesting that i want
you to think about uh because personal
finance is behavior more than it is math
you said i want to get a personal loan
to pay off my two credit cards well
you're really not paying them off you're
just moving them
to a personal life
so a proper way of saying it would have
been hey i want to move my debt over to
a different kind of debt to get a lower
interest rate but i'm going to pay off
my debt
with extremely low lifestyle and a debt
snowball and that's how i'm going to pay
off the debt because you can't borrow
your way out of debt and so that's a
lesson for the rest of our audience
because people say that all the time i'm
going to pay off my debt by borrowing
this no you didn't pay it off you just
moved it and so again all this to say
the budget i think the budget would be
the first step before i'm even worried
about doing the personal loans evidently
because yeah the budget didn't work the
first that's right yeah let's get going
and really get some momentum on on
pounding that 8 500 in the mouth just
beat the snot out of it right and then
when you get then when you get that
moving like you're saying uh if you want
to do the personal loan and save 400
like i said that's that's good there's
nothing wrong with 400 but if you feel
like that got you out of debt then you
were mathematically wrong what gets you
out of debt is zach looking in the
mirror and go hey bubba we're changing
that's a big deal and paying off that
smallest credit card first by keeping
them separate
gives you that momentum as well of like
okay i can do this it's actually working
and it keeps you fueled yeah versus one
one big one that's true you lose the
moment the emotional momentum of the
dead snowball by moving it yeah the dead
snowball is wear it do you know where
that is do you know what the death
stairwell
heard of is
i'll teach you the next segment don't
worry okay bring me up to date on how to
use it i will i'll teach you that's so
you're so kind